primeiramente boa tarde senhoras e
senhores é com muita satisfação e
alegria que eu subo nesse palco aqui
para poder compartilhar um pouco da
minha história com vocês como miguel ele
falou e eu me chamo marcelo tem 40 anos
e ao longo desses 40 anos eu passei por
grandes transformações e eu gostaria de
compartilhar e que de alguma forma ela
fizesse sentido na vida de vocês
bom minha primeira grande transformação
aconteceu aos 19 anos quando eu decidi
que eu iria mudar a minha forma física
como é que aconteceu isso desde o meu
nascimento e já nasce uma criança muito
grande nas cinco mais de cinco quilos
me tornei um adolescente obeso e aos 19
anos eu tomei essa decisão que
revolucionou toda a minha vida
juntamente com isso eu conheci o
jiujitsu que foi a ferramenta que me fez
alcançar esses e na verdade esse
objetivo
é bom tomar essa decisão eu entrei no
esporte o sport ele mudou a minha vida é
eu tinha anteriormente hábitos
completamente destrutivos do esporte ele
me ajudou com hábitos completamente
construtivos em apenas oito meses
eu emagreci 43 quilos e isso teve um
impacto muito forte em todas as searas
da minha vida é bom vamos eu antes de se
matar e cimento eu estudava ciências
contábeis quando eu conheci o sport e
houve essa ressignificação muito grande
na minha vida eu larguei a ciências
contábeis foi fazer educação física ea
partir daí eu cair de cabeça no mundo do
esporte no mundo do jiu jitsu no mundo
da disciplina porque ele tem muito a ver
com disciplina me tornei é competidor
nesse processo eu tive bastante êxito me
tornei multicampeão no cenário nacional
no mundial do do esporte
é com essa resignificação com essa
mudança eu vivia exclusivamente o sport
a minha vida era voltada pra isso
passados dez anos eu estava com uma
insatisfação muito grande dentro de mim
e essa insatisfação ela dizia respeito à
minha saúde financeira
foi quando acendeu um sinal de alerta e
eu falei 'bom eu preciso mudar isso
foi quando houve essa segunda mudança
nesse momento nos grandes amigos
fundadores da gracie barra brasília eles
estavam de malas prontas para ir para a
américa e para a europa porque viver do
jiu jitsu viver do esporte no brasil é
muito difícil e eles estavam com
projetos de viver os seus sonhos lá fora
como de fato eles estão nesse momento eu
vi que esse não era o meu propósito eu
tinha um projeto tem aqui na chapada dos
veadeiros é um projeto pessoal meu
e esse projeto ele vamos dizer ele me
amarrou aqui é bom mas eu tinha aquela
aquela coisa que me incomodava bastante
que era como eu falei essa minha saúde
financeira e ouvir quais eram as minhas
possibilidades dentro do cenário até no
momento foi em 2004
naquela época brasília ela transpirava
concurso público e eu como não tinha
nenhum outra meta estavam tanto quanto
perdido o concurso público ele é muito
mérito cra tico né depende só de você de
mais ninguém eu entrei nessa seara
eu falei bom vou começar a estudar para
concurso assim que eu entrei no mundo do
concurso público e eu vi o abismo que a
van do meu objetivo
bom comecei a traçar uma estratégia para
poder alcançar esse objetivo e logo
houve com fundo
o buraco porque dentro eu não sei se
aqui alguém estudou para concurso
público
mas se aprovado no concurso público é
você ser o melhor entre os melhores é
muito acirrado é um caminho muito
espinhoso
logo eu fui no esporte
eu fui no jiu jitsu em toda a minha
vivência peguei todas as ferramentas que
fizeram muito sentido pra mim que
mudaram a minha vida ea partir daí eu
comecei a focar e montar a minha
estratégia para poder alcançar
resultados e alcançar resultados naquilo
que eu havia escolhido
bom isso tudo muito no modo empírico né
na tentativa e erro
paralelo a isso eu comecei a lê grandes
autores como anthony robbins xavier que
eles vinham uma teoria eles falavam tudo
aquilo que eu estava colocando na
prática e para mim foi genial porque eu
consegui associar as duas coisas
eu comecei a unir essas duas coisas
e por incrível que pareça eu descobrir
vamos dizer uma forma uma fórmula de se
obter resultados e eu vim compartilhar
essa fórmula com vocês
bom a fórmula é muito simples
sentimentos desculpa pensamentos geram
sentimentos sentimentos ele geram ação e
o conjunto de pensamentos sentimentos e
ação ele geram o seu resultado
marcelo é só isso é só isso agora eu vou
falar detalhadamente um pouquinho de
cada coisa
bom antes de eu entrar no pensamento
propriamente dito vou falar sobre o
campo vibracional hoje já é bem
difundida através da física quântica que
tudo no universo é energia
se tudo é energia existe os campos
vibracionais aonde essa energia que é
fluida ela transita
vamos separar aqui essas duas energias
em positiva e negativa
se você vibra numa energia positiva
você vai atrair coisas positivas se você
vibra em coisas negativas a
possibilidade de você atrair coisas
negativas é muito grande
bom isso é a lei da atratividade
concomitante com isso existem dois
grupos de pessoas no planeta as pessoas
que vivem de forma consciente e as
pessoas que vivem de forma inconsciente
o que eu quero te dizer que as pessoas
que vivem de forma inconsciente ou elas
vivem com medo do futuro ou com remorso
do passado e pouco ela se atém no
presente eo presente nada mais é que o
presente continuado nada mais é do que o
nosso futuro o nosso destino a existe um
outro lado que são as pessoas
conscientes dessas pessoas conscientes
eu falo que nelas não vivem 24 horas por
dia de forma consciente elas têm
momentos de consciência
são pessoas que questionam mais que vem
o valor da vida que não acredita em tudo
aquilo que é falado né
hoje com o advento da tecnologia as
pessoas virem muito conectados com o
mundo e talvez desconectados com elas
mesmo então por que eu quero dizer com
isso que você se perceber o campo
vibracional que você está
os seus tipos de pensamento se você
percebe que você é uma pessoa que está
presente no seu presente
você vai gerar o que autoconhecimento e
já dizia aristóteles conheça te a ti
mesmo o pai da filosofia o
autoconhecimento para mim é a primeira
coisa para você começar a se perceber ea
partir daí tomar as suas decisões
falar de pensamento é negativo e
positivo é uma coisa até intuitiva para
vocês porque às vezes a gente se percebe
quando a gente tá com
nossos pensamentos melhores o que os
nossos pensamentos piores dentro do
pensamento negativo eu vou elencar um
ponto que pra mim é muito importante que
é as crenças limitantes essas crenças
limitantes às vezes a gente não percebe
porque elas vem nos acompanhando ao
longo de uma vida e elas são colocadas
na nossa vida de forma implícita de
forma velada são coisas que nós trazemos
inclusive da nossa família dos nossos
avós dos nossos pais da sociedade da
mídia das instituições e essas crenças
limitantes se nós não tomarmos cuidado
elas nos acorrentam porquê porque hoje
nós vivemos muito a cultura do medo é eu
ouvi uma frase um tempo atrás fez muito
sentido pra mim que é pra que você
acorrentar as pessoas se você pode
aprisionar las pelo medo então medo na
verdade é uma forma de você for matar e
deixar as pessoas vão dizer doutrinados
e essas crenças limitantes
talvez as impeçam você de viver os seus
sonhos né
vamos trazer um exemplo que vamos ver um
menino de 12 anos que chega para o pai
fala pai eu quero ser surfista o pai vai
olhar e falar meu filho pelo amor de
deus surfista surfista coisa de
vagabundo surfista né
enfim mas imagina se o gabriel medina
tivesse ouvido isso e tivesse aceitado e
esse talvez ele não seria o que ele é
hoje talvez ele não vivesse o sonho dele
talvez ele não impactasse tantas vidas
como ele vem impactando né ao longo da
sua curtíssima carreira então essas
crenças limitantes são coisas que nós
temos que nos ater e perceber mesmo não
conseguindo visualizá-las bom o
pensamento ele gera um sentimento
sentimento aquilo que te move aquilo que
faz acordar todos os dias
na verdade eu falo que são os porquês
que a gente tem quando a gente tem um
determinado projeto quando a gente tem
uma determinada decisão
a gente tem que ter esse sentimento alto
o seu porque alto porque senão fica
muito fácil a gente desistir
quem nunca desistiu de um curso de
línguas de um esporte de uma academia de
uma dieta né
então quando você coloca esse porque
muito alto e se porque é o seu
combustível para que você não desista
o que eu gosto de falar é que se você
colocar o seu porque maior do que você
na sua família nos seus filhos nos seus
sonhos talvez você tenha mais
persistência em continuar a seguir os
seus objetivos
bom a decisão ela é pra mim o ponto de
partida para qualquer ação a decisão ela
molda o seu destino
todos os dias nós tomamos várias
decisões mas será que essas decisões são
decisões que realmente mudam a nossa
vida ou nós tomamos decisões paliativas
decisões que não impacta em nada a nossa
vida o ser humano ele tem a capacidade
muito grande de procrastinar que é
deixar de fazer aquilo que realmente tem
que ser feito
bom a partir dessa decisão uma decisão
ela só é realmente efetivamente uma
decisão quando ela vem seguida de uma
ação
se você acha que você toma uma decisão e
não vinculou uma ação nessa decisão você
não tomou essa decisão
a decisão é o que materializa as coisas
o pensamento o sentimento
a decisão é uma parte mas o que faz
realmente a coisa acontecer é ação eu
coloquei algumas características de
ações que fazem você otimizar o seu
processo por exemplo organização
pra mim é o começo de tudo você se
voltar pra você porque a grande mudança
mesmo que você queira uma mudança muito
grande que envolva outras pessoas
primeiro você tem que mudar a si mesmo
então você tem que começar a olhar para
a sua
vida começará a ver como é que está a
sua vida pessoal a sua vida financeira e
organizar essas coisas eu faço inclusive
um convite a vocês
ao chegar em casa abrir os armários
gavetas aquilo que a gente tem de mais
íntimo e percebam que se você estiver
com tudo muito desorganizado há uma
possibilidade grande da vida também está
desorganizada é o planejamento o
planejamento
ele é pra mim
os seus olhos a longo prazo a pessoa que
não se planeja ou ela sobrevive ou ela
faz parte de um projeto de uma outra
pessoa eu falo com as pessoas
os meus filhos com as pessoas que me
cercam crie metas a curto a médio ea
longo prazo se visualizem daqui a um ano
daqui a cinco anos daqui a dez anos como
é que vocês querem estar porque a partir
daí vocês começam a perceber as
ferramentas vocês precisam utilizar
quais mudanças de hábito né e esse
planejamento
ele tem que vir seguido de uma
disciplina porque a disciplina a
disciplina é um tijolinho que nós
construímos todos os dias nós montamos
grandes projectos mas é o dia a dia é o
presente continuado que vai fazer o
nosso futuro e esse futuro ele é
construído através da gente em ti não
pode terceirizar isso para uma outra
pessoa isso é responsabilidade nossa e à
disciplina é fazer o que tem que fazer
mesmo não querendo fazer é quando você
se é exibir dos pequenos prazeres dos
prazeres momentâneos em prol de um
prazer maior de um prazer a longo prazo
bom a persistência ea resiliência é o
que te faz não desistir eu vejo muitas
pessoas que com todas essas ferramentas
estão quase chegando aos seus objetivos
mais cansados eles acabam desistindo
eu gosto de dar o exemplo da fila de um
banco que ao chegar no banco você ver
uma fila muito grande você entra naquela
fila várias pessoas vão existir outras
pessoas falam eu tenho que embora depois
eu volto se você continuar naquela fila
invariavelmente você vai chegar na boca
do caixa e você vai ser atendido então a
persistência não existência
para mim é a chave principal desse
dessas desse alcance desse grandes
resultados
bom todos esses elementos o pensamento
sentimento a decisão a ação o ovo geral
que vão gerar o que a gente chama de
destino eu gosto de chamar de resultado
o destino a gente acaba terceirizando né
a gente coloca isso na mão de outra
pessoa e eu não acredito em sorte ou
azar destino acredito em trabalho
perseverança disciplina e eu acredito
que a gente constrói a cama que a gente
deita e eu vou deixar vocês aqui com uma
frase que ouvi que fez bastante sentido
pra mim que você não é aquilo que você
pensa que é
você não é aquilo que os outros pensam
que você é você é o seu resultado
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]